Transcriber: Hala Abdullah
المدقّق: rana heloun
مساء الخير جميعًا،
يُشرفني أقف معكم طبعًا.
اسمي (إيفا داوود) كما عرّفوا عني،
أنا أم لأربع بنات
الكبيرة اسمها (نور)
وهي طبيبة على وشك التّخصّص،
والصغيرة طالبة بكالوريا.
والفتاتين الأخرييْن، واحدة اسمها
(شوارب) عمرها سنة،
والثانية تُدعى (زمّيرا) عمرها أربعة أشهر.
(نور) و(ساما) معي هنا،
(زمّيرة) و(شوارب) تركتهما في البيت
لكي لا يزعجوننا بأصواتهما مياو مياو مياو
طيلة الوقت.
أنا، منذ صغري، أحب أن سافر،
أحب اكتشاف الحضارات،
ولديّ الشغف
بما خلف المحيط
وما خلف سوريا.
أحترم الآخر في أي مكان من العالم،
أحترم ثقافات الشعوب وعاداتها وتقاليدها.
ولديّ فضول كبير بالعلوم
والماورائيات وديانات الشعوب.
وقد سافرت فعلًا.
في حياتي العملية، تعرفت وكنت
محظوظة بأنني تعرّفت
على كثير من المبدعين الشغوفين الملهمين
المخترعين حتى العباقرة
وكنت سعيدة ومحظوظة
بالتعامل مع هؤلاء الناس.
قبل أن أترك سوريا،
كنت طالبة سنة أولى في الجامعة،
وفي ذاك الوقت -أنا مواليد سنة خمس وسبعين-
وفي ذاك الوقت، في التسعين الأولى،
استطعت أنا كطالبة أن أحصل على وظيفتين
في الأولى، كنت وكيلة خط ناقل
بشركة نقل بحري وكانت تابعة للقطاع الحكومي.
والثانية كنت -الوظيفتين في الوقت نفسه-
مدرّسة بديلة في إحدى المنظمات
الأممية في سوريا،
وكل راتب من الوظيفتين على حدى
كان يعتبر جيد
في عام ثلاثة وتسعين تقريباً،
لأي طالبة خريجة، ليس لمجرد طالبة
للخريجات كان هذا العمل هو حلم.
طبعا وصلت إلى هذا الشيء
باجتهادي وفضولي
وكانت أمي دائمًا وأتوقع أنها مازالت
تُلقّبني بالأخطبوط
قاصدةً أنني أمتلك أيادي وأرجل في كل مكان.
أحب أن أتثقّف وأحب أن اكتشف.
وعندما سافرت خارج سوريا
عملت في مجالات عديدة،
عملت في محطة إي آر تي الرياضية،
وعملت في مجال الصحافة،
وكذلك عملت في مجال
تطويرالصناعات المتقدمة
كصناعة القطارات في أوروبا،
ومن خلال عملي، استطعت أن أتكفّل
بتكاليف دراستي وحياتي.
طبعًا،
بمجرد أن تقول امرأة في مجتمعنا
السوري أو العربي
تحقق أي من الأمور التي ذكرتها لكم
السفر
وتأهيل عالي علمي،
-فأنا أحمل دكتوراه بالاقتصاد-
ولديها أولاد وحياتها ناجحة،
حتى أنها تمتلك حيوانات،
وسافرت وعملت،
في نظر الجميع
كـ “امرأة”
أنتِ محظوظة.
لمجرد أن تحققي أمر واحد أو اثنين
من الأمور التي ذكرتها كامرأة عربية،
سيقول الناس بأنك محظوظة.
هل هذا صحيح؟!
هذا الشق الأول من الحقيقة.
أما الشق الثاني من الحقيقة فهو السبب
الذي دفعني للوقوف هنا والتحدّث به معكم،
لم أكن سعيدة،
أبداً!
استطعت أن أتنقّل في مجالات كثيرة
وعملت بها وحققت نجاحات بها،
كنت أنام كل يوم على الوسادة
وأنا حزينة..
لا يوجد أي شيء،
وفي داخلي فراغ
في داخلي، في وجهي تأخذني دوامة،
أنا لست سعيدة!
لم أكن أعرف، ولم أكن أمتلك الجرأة
لأخبر أحد أن “(إيفا) ليست سعيدة”،
لأنه بمجرد أن تقول لأحد أنك لست سعيد
فالكلمة الأولى التي ستخطر ببال
التقليديين “أنتِ تُسرفين بالنعمة”
“لقد أعطاكِ الله كل شيء،
ولست سعيدة!
ماذا تريدين أكثر؟”
نعم، لم أكن سعيدة
ولا يُعتبر هذا إسرافًا أبدًا.
لكنني صريحة جداً مع نفسي،
في داخلي فراغ.
مرة من المرات، كنت أشاهد مع زوجي
-الذي بسببه أقف هنا على هذه المنصة-
فلماً اسمه (مملكة نارنيا)،
هذا الفلم هو من أدب
الأطفال العالمي الخيالي
وتدور أحداثه حول ممالك ساحرات
وحيوانات ناطقة
وعوالم أخرى وصراع بينهم،
بعد انتهاء الفلم،
بكيت
قال لي زوجي “لماذا تبكين فالفلم لا يُبكي؟”
قلت له: “لطالما تمنيت أن أكون مخرجة“،
نظر إليّ وقال لي:
“حسب علمي لطالما أحببتِ أن
تكوني رائدة فضاء وليس مخرجة”
قلت له: “؟رائدة فضاء وأنا من جيل الخمسة
وسبعين وقد أكملت دراستي هنا في سوريا!!
بمجرد أن تكبر سنة بعد سنة ستعرف
أنه عليك نسيان حلم رائدة الفضاء“.
فقال لي: “لكن ليس المخرجة!”
قلت له: “من الطبيعي
ألّا أحدّثك،
لأن الحلم بحد ذاته
لم أستطع أن أتكلّم بصراحة”.
لأنه عند الحصول على البكالوريا هنا
أو في أي مكان عربي..
دعونا نتكلم عن تجربة امرأة عربية
ليست سورية وحسب،
إذا أردت دراسة الإخراج،
بعد التخرج سيقولون لك ادرسي
طب، صيدلة، حقوق، هندسة، فلسفة،
أي شيء تكسبين منه قوت يومك.
حتى عندما تخرجت
- ولدي أهل رائعين طبعاً-
عندما أخبرتهم بأنني أريد أن أدرس إخراج
هكذا هو الموضوع،
ليس لدينا مدرسة تدريس إخراج أو أكاديمية
قالوا لي:“ادرسي اختصاصًا يعيلك في المستقبل
ويصنع لك قاعدة صخرية ثابتة لحياتك“.
إذا أردت أن تقول لأهلك أودّ
السفر بغية أن أدرس الإخراج
بمجرد أن تكون شاب -ليست فتاة-
و أن يقول سفّروني..
نحن دائما عند الاستثمار بالعلم
لابنك أو لابنتك
عندما تقول لأهلك أريد أن أدرس
الطب أو الهندسة فيدعماك،
حتى لو أن وضعهما
المالي الاقتصادي ليس جيدا،
يقومون بذلك استثمارًا بابنهما أو بابنتهما
ليرجعوا بشهادات علمية.
مثلا أريد أن أدرس الطب يا أبي
حسنًا يا بني
اذهب وادرس في أمريكا أو فرنسا
أو في مصر أو أي مكانٍ آخر.
لكن أن تقول لهما بأنك تريد أن تدرس فن
وفي ذاك الوقت فلا يستثمروا بالفن،
بصراحة إنه بحد ذاته استثمار خاسر بناءً
على التفكير العام الشمولي بمجتمعاتنا،
فما بالك بفتاة تريد
أن تستثمر بدراسة الإخراج.
في عيد الأم،
فاجأني زوجي وبناتي بهدية
والتي هي انتساب لأكاديمية
عالمية لصناعة السينما،
فرحت وبكيت وقلت لهم:” لا، مستحيل“،
فسألوني“لماذا؟”
قلت لهم: “كيف لي وأنا في هذا
العمر أن أدرس السينما!”
فابنتي نور كانت بعمر تقريباً يقارب
عمر الطلاب الذين سأدرس معهم
في هذه الأكاديمية العالمية لصناعة السينما.
لقد خجلت!
خجلت لسببين.
السبب الأول: لأنني كبيرة، وابنتي من جيلهم،
بفارق عمر سنتين فقط!
والثاني: هو أنني ضعيفة جدًا بالتكنولوجيا،
فأنا أرى أولادي سريعين بأمور التكنولوجيا،
أما أنا، فأستخدم التكنولوجيا
حسب احتياجاتي الشخصية،
لكن هذا الجيل سريع للغاية.
أصرّوا أن أدرس الإخراج.
وقال لي زوجي جملة:
“(إيفا) اذهبي وادرسي الإخراج
فربما يكون كحلم رائد الفضاء،
مجرد حلم طفولي وحسب
ومع مرور الوقت يتلاشى الحلم،
وإن لم يكن حلمًا طفوليًا، ستكونين قد
عرفتِ أمرًا تحبينه وتعلّمتيه“.
أصرّ علي، فذهبتُ، وفعلاً كما أخبرتكم
عندما وصلت الأكاديمية
تفاجأتُ بالطلاب في الصف
فهم تقريبًا من عمر ابنتي
أكبر طالبٍ بينهم كان من
مواليد الخمسة والثمانين
وأنا من مواليد الخمسة والسبعين،
وهذا الأقرب سناً،
فأنا كنت أقرب للدكاترة والمحاضرين في العمر
من أن أكون قريبة للطلبة،
أضيفوا إلى ذلك
عندما يعدوا رفقائي في الصف
تقنيات الكاميرا
بهذه السرعة
بينما أستغرق يومًا
فالعمل الذي يقومون به في نصف ساعة،
يحتاج مني يومًا كاملًا.
في عمليات المونتاج،
يستغرق منهم الأمر عشر دقائق
صدقاً، يستغرق مني يومًا
وبالاستعانة بصديق.
توجهت إلى بروفيسوري الذي يعلّمني السينما
وقلت له “بروفيسور أنا بطيئة
أي مقارنتي بطلاب الصف بالتكنولوجيا
كمقارنة سرعة سيارة فراري بحلزونة”
طبعًا وبالتأكيد لم أكن سيارة الفراري.
أذكر أن (نورمال)- الذي هو بروفيسوري-
سألني: “هل أنتِ مُخرجة أم تقني سينمائي؟”
قلت له “لا، أنا أدرس الإخراج”
قال لي: “كطالبة إخراج، أنتِ بحاجة
إلى أن تعرفي تقنيات العمل السينمائي
لأنه ستحتاجينها في يوم من الأيام
لكي تختاري فريق جيد يكون معك
لذا، فهذا ليس من عملك، أنتِ مُخرجة لكن
عليك أن تعرفي تقنيات لتجيدي اختيار فريقك”
والذي حدث..
عندما ذهبت للمرة الأولى إلى استوديوهات
صناعة السينما لصناعة الفيلم الأول والثاني
بكلّ صدق
نسيت أنني متزوجة،
نسيت أنه لدي أولاد،
نسيت أيّ شي،
والغريب أنه- وللمرة الأولى-
بعد كل هذه السنين
أنا سعيدة
وسعيدة جدًا
ومنذ ذلك اليوم..
شكرًا.
منذ ذلك اليوم ليومنا هذا،
لم أعد أشعر بالحزن
ولا بالفراغ
أذكره، وأنا أقف أمامكم أذكره
أذكر تلك الدّوامة التي كانت تجرفني،
علمت أنني وجدتُ قطعتي الناقصة
أنا بصدق من الداخل
قطعتي الناقصة ليست كما يريد الناس
أن تكون سعادتي أنا (إيفا)
أو سعادة حضرتك،
أنا وجدت القطعة الناقصة داخلي
ومنذ ذلك الحين،
حياتي اختلفت بجد
ك(إيفا) أصبحت أسعد،
ولم أعد أتنقل بين الوظائف،
ولم يكن بسبب الملل
لكن الدافع الذي بسببه أقف هنا أمامكم
لأخبركم اليوم بكل سعادة وشرف
أن الأمر الذي أخافني من أن أدرس الإخراج
والحزن الذي لم أتجرّأ أن أبوح به لأحد
هو الدافع الذي بسببه أقف هنا
لأخبركم وأقول لكِ
لا تخافِ!
لا تخافِ أبدًا!
فالمجتمع العربي تحديداً موجود دائما ليحبطك
ليسرق حلمِك،
ليخيفك من عمرك،
ليحد من سعادتك،
تزوّجي لتكوني سعيدة،
احصلي على الدكتوراه لتصبحي سعيدة،
توظّفي واحصلي على راتب جيد لتكوني سعيدة.
حددي سعادتك بنفسك،
واعرفي ماذا تريدين
الحياة على وسعها وعلى مداها
موجودة قطع ناقصة لنا كلنا،
عليك فقط مدّ يدك للامساك بها.
لم يعد العلم رفاهية.
ولم تعد المعرفة رفاهية.
في منزلكِ، وبوسائل التكنولوجيا
التي كنت أشبه الحلزونة بها،
موجودة ومتوفرة بين أياديكن،
تعرّفي، تعلّمي، ابحثي عن قطعتِك الناقصة
وعن شغفك وعن مكانتك المناسبة،
زيدي مهاراتِك،
لا تخافي في يوم من الأيام
ربما تكون القطعة الناقصة لأحد الموجودين
أن يتسلق جبل (ايفيريست)،
وقد تواجهين أناس يقولون لكِ:
“ما هذه المهزلة!”
لا تستمعي لهم،
وتسلّقي جبل ايفيريست.
ربما يكون شغف إحدى الموجودات
أن تطوّر حرفة سورية
قاربت على الانقراض وتسوق لها،
فتسمع المجتمع- قبل أن تبدأ- يقول لها:
“ما هذه المهزلة! تسرفين أموالك هباء”
لا تدعي أحدا يحاصرك بمحدودية عقله،
ابقي بوسع محدوديتك
أنتِ من الداخل ما هي القطعة التي تجدينها،
قد لا تعرفون قطعتكم
وقد يتساءل معظمكم اليوم
“ما هي قطعتي الناقصة؟”
لا يعرف كل شخص منا قطعته الناقصة
لكن لا تخجلوا، بل حاولوا أن تعرفوا
وأتمنّى منكم عندما تجدون قطعتكم الناقصة،
كل فتاة وسيدة معنا
شاركي تجربة نجاحك مع
أي عابرة سبيل لو في حديقة
لكي نلهم بعضنا بعضًا
ولأننا نستطيع من خلال تجاربنا الصادقة
ومن خلال نجاحنا، نستطيع أن نعلّم،
نستطيع أن نكسر حاجز الخوف
وهذا الأمر يجعلك تدركين فعلًا معنى السعادة
وتدركين معنى النجاح
بكل ما في الكلمة من معنى.
من العيون التي أراها وأنا أتلفّت
يمين ويسار، قادرة أن أرى بعيونكم
ومعظم الصبايا
كأن كل واحد منكم يبحث عن قطعة ناقصة.
فكروا، لاقوها، جربوا.
وأتمنى في يوم من الأيام أن أسمع
بتجارب لكم ناجحة مختلفة
وأنا أوعدكم،
ممكن بأربع سنوات من الآن
أن تروا صوري كرائد فضاء
لكن ليس بالفضاء،
بل خدعة سينمائية.
أحبكم كثيرًا،
شكرا.